Hello everyone. It's a great pleasure to
present here for AI engineer worlds fair
2025. My name is Hbert Mishtella. I work
for Novardis where I lead AI researchers
in drug design. But today I would like
to talk about slightly different topic
which is agentic enterprise. What your
CEO must know about AI. So today I'm
going to walk you through a few
different angles of AI. um specifically
workflows, network and some challenges
and individual perspective as well,
individual employees perspective of how
we can start thinking a little bit about
the future of how a agents might be used
and how they can impact our organization
and how we can prepare for that. So
let's get into it.
I'll start with a little bit provocative
statement which
is in three years maybe your
organization will be run already by AI
agents again maybe provocative but I
believe it's still realistic within the
pace of AI and AI agents which we have
right now let's define first what AI
agent really is as some of you might
already know AI agent is an large
language model based application
exhibiting certain autonomy in its
behavior. AI agents are composed of
language model which glues together
specific things. It executes with
planning step by in a step-by-step
fashion usage of different tools, right?
And the usage of those tools can be
adjusted depending on the outcome of
previous steps and on the steps. And
that's that's called dynamic action.
why it matters because it this provides
us with another level of capabilities
previously almost unique to humans. But
before we get to that, let me say one
thing and that is many companies already
and every company should be working on
already on digital assets and really
morphing them or evolving them to for
the usage of AI agents. So you can think
about it this way. Every digital asset
in your organization should become a
tool for AI agent retentmented
generation itself or an
agent and these capabilities are really
reasoning for multi-step planning
adaptability for dynamic work uh
control persistent memory contextual
talk related to the fact that some
sometimes we want to use only specific
knowledge which is not available able in
language model and this is where we
start talking about retrieval augmented
generation or interactive sun uh uh
workspaces like sandboxes or canvas
where we iteratively can work with an AA
agent as a collaborator to refine
specific job like for example code or
specific piece of art. And last but not
least capability is computer using
agents. those can navigate graphical
user interface to help us
automate steps uh which previously again
only humans were were were able to do
and sometimes robotic processes
automation. Now let me go
to first perspective which is process
perspective or in other words workflow.
Workflow is the actually execution of a
certain process. So imagine you have a
process in your company and you want to
execute that process. You define a
workflow which is defined by in this
case five steps sequential steps
executed from left to right. Some of
those steps might be commoditized simple
others might be specialized specialized
tasks. This uh this design beautifully
simple but very explanatory was was uh
done for the first time I guess by
Sanjit recommendable blog posts.
wonderful reads. So starting with that I
wanted to point out that technology
might be used in two ways.
One automation another one is
augmentation. So automation really is
that we substitute with the technology
specific step and augmentation is doing
that step or quicker or
better. But wait a minute, couldn't we
do that before with machine learning?
Yes. Yes. some of the tasks we were able
to automate or augment with machine
learning or maybe even without machine
learning, right? So what's the
difference today? So the difference
today comes with agentic workflow and
that's that's where the title of the
this presentation comes from. So why can
we do it right now? We can do it right
now for because of two reasons. First
reason is the fact that language models
or specifically a AI agents
um can tackle broader set of tasks
operating on our thoughts or cognitive
steps usually
represented quite precisely in natural
language. And the second fact is that
language models and a agents can act as
a glue between those tasks. So we can
compose them together and we don't need
a human intervention and human
intervention would be necessary only to
provide the feedback in a certain step
when the agent needs it. So in that
situation what you see in pink we call
agentic workflow right so with this we
can automate and delegate not only one
but a few steps and that's what AI
agents enables us and I want to focus on
this aspect throughout this presentation
now from a few other angles.
So first takeaway is to start building
engine build building agents you need to
first identify your workflows right then
you need to understand the exact context
around them and that's that's a big um
challenge very often because
uh more often than not that context
which is what kind of data is used what
kind of systems are used what kind of
transformation and steps are being
executed on the machine are usually only
in the head of the executive of of the
employee and usually it might be not
locked anywhere. Some of the companies
might be doing that others don't but
very often we conduct um specific steps
in our work without putting it anywhere
because this is this is sometimes you
have to work just quickly. You need to
perform. you need to invent right and
then you start repeating that newly
creative process. So that's a big
challenge because that's buried under
our heads and maybe in distributed even
across the teams or systems. So that's
that's a first uh first thing which
company wanting to make use of a agent
should focus identifying
workflows and identifying deep context
around
them. So let's now try to take a closer
look at the same process at the same
workflow where we have a certain steps.
Now imagine not one person but a group
of people is executing that uh that
workflow right in each step you can have
one or two people in this case and the
manager.
This just tell you about the number of
people, right? Or the the
the position they occupy, right? But
does this really tell you give you the
big the big picture? I don't think so.
Relying relying solely on the
traditional roles and job titles might
be not enough for for usage of AI
because when you want to apply an AI
agent, you need to understand exactly
what kind of tools you want to use. uh
how you can plan, what are the
conditions for changing the behavior and
that's where you need to get deeper and
it's not explained by maybe
documentation or maybe just the position
job description but what might be very
helpful is an interesting angle and
that's a network
perspective.
So when we take let me come back when we
take the whole network of other
employees we can start thinking about it
as different archetypes or different
personas. So when you when we think
about each contributor to the given
workflow as a persona then we can start
getting a little bit more information.
So let's as an example, conceptual
example let's define here five different
personas. One would be silent achiever
person with a let's say uh lower
communication but very good performance.
Then individual
contributor which would have both. Then
the connector connecting non-adjacent
teams in the
organization multiple teams let's say
multiplier person who who enhances the
work of other team members and knowledge
hub providing domain expertise or
necessary information in the process. So
now why am I saying this? Because when
we define the personas in our in our
workflow, right? We can start thinking
already about how AI agents might impact
our workflow and our specific employees.
When you think only about the job
titles, that's a little bit harder. But
when you think, oh, they both have the
same job title, but that person behaves
differently than that person. they
really contribute in a different
fashion. So that's what you when you can
start optimizing for the agents and one
can say okay we have that information in
our team so that's not necessary but
wait a minute that's presentation is
just for the CEO as I said so you need
to have a more detailed look at the
organization at the global level to be
able to understand what are the
similarities and differences between the
teams because when you realize that for
example
um let me speed it up a little
H when you when you realized for example
that um there is a certain pattern
repeating in two different workflows
then you can optimize for those two
workflows. So first
takeaway around a network of personas is
that if you want your organization and
people adapt to AI then maybe looking at
the personas might be helpful first step
and let me show you how. Let's now try
to project how that same that same
workflow might look like with AI
agents. So first as you can see
difference from the previous slide. Let
me come back one more time. Here we had
two steps and now these two steps merged
into one step. Why? Because of one
reason because of that silent achiever
who got an access to coding assistant
might become so productive that now he
can he can do the work for a few people
for two steps
already. On top of
that the same coding assistant might be
used for other team members and they are
again more efficient. So they don't need
to perform the work
in two people don't need to to perform
the same work for for one task but one
person per per per task in the in the
workflow. Now another agent would be
agent magnifying the the communication
and the and the impact of the multiplier
persona on other on other uh team
members. So for example, previously that
uh that persona was impacting only the
adjacent team members. But now with the
with with the help of AI agent that can
be magnified to all of the team members
and now they could become higher
performance with a better
communication. Right? So you see already
that these things sum up together or
multiply together.
Even another agent would be for
knowledge hub. So that probably is one
of the personas which would be the most
prone again personas not positions
personas most prone for substitution of
an AA agent because you can um prepare a
knowledge hop in such a way that it
dynamically that's what I try to depict
with a with this bigger arrow that it
doesn't support one or two specific team
members but all
team and then that person who was
working on that workflow can
now take this whole workflow at the
bottom. Right? And there is efficiency
across the board which one can try to
imagine. But my point here really is
um it's not only about the workflow or
the structure, right? Because they will
be changing very dynamically. It's more
about um understanding the archetypes or
the profiles or the personas of the of
the employees working on different
workflows. And that's where it would be
much easier to start projecting and
planning for the development of
different agents because imagine for
example that you verify this workflow
for uh you you do this analysis for all
of the workflows in your company and you
realize ah we have the same issue always
on the first step and and that that's
when you know what kind of agents you
need to build for for the
optimization with this. Let me move to
another uh another part of it uh which
is the list of emerging patterns. So
based on the previous uh analysis you
can start come to the to a few questions
and conclusions. Let me start with the
questions. First question would be which
tasks really in that workflow would be
better for humans to be executed and
which of them would be better to be
executed by AA
agents. And
um referring back to to to the challenge
about the context, I would say that
ambiguous workflows where a lot depends
upon the situation and it's not clear
how to define it, obviously it's going
to be better executed by humans. And in
the situation when you want to keep the
subjectivity in place, that's also when
you want to still have a human in place
because maybe you don't care about the
subjectivity. Maybe it's a feature, not
a bug. On the other hand, you might want
to remove that subjectivity and that's
when you use the agent. You might also
want to use the agent obviously when
something is repetitive and tedious and
and you want to perform it perfectly in
the same fashion every single time. So
there there there is
there's obvious or maybe not so obvious
start of the analysis. Then we see
already some some emerging patterns and
one of them is that intelligence and the
domain knowledge be becomes commodity
which means they become cheap easily
available and that's not the age edge
anymore of the employees. So that tells
us that the employees and companies
maybe because if a company has an edge
because of the domain knowledge and
intelligence
uh on average let's say um that that's
not going to be an a an an advantage
anymore. So
one employee or a
company has to start pivoting to get
multi-disiplinary knowh how or get much
deeper into specific into specific area.
So we see so also some patterns uh
online appearing that in engineers and
this is what I depicted there as well
that some of the senior engineers are
being dragged from the engineering teams
and working directly with the product uh
with with the domain experts experts on
the product because they can develop
much quicker with assistants and they
can communicate with the domain experts
much quicker thanks to domain assistant
agents. then we can use agents as super
connectors. Uh context understanding
will gain more value in contrast to
intelligence or domain expertise. That
that's the difference between domain
expertise and the context. I'm not going
to get into the detail but I wanted to
highlight that as
well and AI supercharger supercharges
and supercharges doers. So people who do
and perform can do even more and
quicker. So the magnitude of the
difference might be huge. It some people
say talk about 10 times engineer. In
reality we might be talking even about
100 times engineer and less of middle
grounds. I think uh what's going to
happen is we're going to see a lot of
polarization in the positions in the
tasks. So we're going to be have we have
to we will have to go specializing and
those specializations might be very new.
So let me show you what will appear or
what might appear. We can see new roles
in AI mature organizations like workflow
minor as I mentioned before there are
already companies work with a great
experience around that right then you
can have human AI orchestrator because
for example you might need to
orchestrate that interaction between
human and AI and how you do that that
would be that position and so on. I'm
not going to get into the details you
get the idea.
Um
now the big point for uh or takeaway for
uh executives in my opinion would be how
you can enable all of your organization
to start adopting uh or democratizing
all of this.
So it goes step by steps obviously step
by step obviously first you give the
access to general assistants right
that's probably in place in all of the
companies then you give the access to
individual assistants per employee with
a memory with adjustments with
understanding the context with personal
database and so on that allows the
employee to work closer on this context
and don't repeat every single time the
same
thing then we can get to new
capabilities and that's very important.
If we want to build those optimized
workflows, right, or maybe redefined
even workflows, we need to build those
agents very quickly. And one of the
angles of building those agents very
quickly is building by the employees
themselves. So there is a the key fe key
skill set skill or capability which I
believe will change the organizations
tremendously is building the agents on
the spot and we have those capabilities
across the board with with brilliant
coding assistant
tools no or or or no code and low code
tools, right? But before employees can
get to that, they need to work on a
cognitive scale, which would be
self-awareness of what I really think at
work, what kind of steps I really
perform in my head and on different
systems to get to that goal which is
only visible at the very end and that's
what everybody else only sees. I I do
much more inside of that process, right?
Inside of that workflow. So that
requires cognitive um self-awareness
let's say to translate it into specific
steps and then build with no code low
code or maybe code agent to do that for
me as a lot of data scientists already
do. So another step would be digital
twins like time travelers and memory to
retain the uh organizational knowledge.
So imagine you have an employee with
many years of experience. If that
employee leaves, all the knowhow is
gone, right? With an exception of some
of the documents or presentations maybe.
But now imagine you have an agent
representing that employee and the
knowledge and the previous expertise and
you can ask questions and you can time
travel back not like your lost history
or somewhere, right? You can just come
back and explicitly reconstruct that and
ask questions.
Um, another level would be agents with
multiple employees. So, agents serving
not only one employee but the whole team
or the whole workflow. And then of
course we're going to get to the swarm
of agents which we already have software
ready. And all of this is really enabled
only now because we are getting to the
mature point of the software software
stacked around LLMs and AI agents.
So with that let me go to another
element
uh which is the angle of uh challenges
and opportunities. We all know about the
well about the challenges which is uh
groundedness uh hallucinations guard
rails security and everything else. I
wanted to discuss briefly here the
bottom two of them which is ethics and
adoption. Let's start with the adoption.
So on the right you see a table from
deep mind from
uh two years ago
202023 where they discuss different
levels of AGI or intelligence and when
you read it carefully you're going to
notice that this part of the table is
when human drives interaction and that
bottom part of the table is where AI
start driving
interaction or the specific execution
and that might be an adoption proc.
problem. Are we really ready for not
delegating but really giving the whole
task to the to the agent and letting the
agent delegate subtasks to us? That's a
big adoption culture question which
uh which which we need to resolve before
we get get further. Right? Of course,
first we need to start start applying
simple agents. But the question is are
we really ready
socially? And then the second aspect is
the ethics of autonomy. So with that we
are we are getting a few a few um
interesting but challenging questions
right. Um so it and it's not even about
about about
uh traditional philosophical questions
uh uh like whether agents should act as
A or B in a in a certain situation but
it's rather first we want the AI agents
to help us and support us as value
keepers right but what kind of values do
do we want those agents to be stored
that has to be explicitly defined. We
humans don't agree with everything but
we need to define something for the
agents. That's going to be first
challenge. And the second challenge
which is even I think more interesting
but because that's that's a new one
which is about the interaction and
conflict between human and AI. How we
going to resolve that with another AI
agent justice agent?
Maybe these are the things which which
we will need to figure out. Uh let me
wrap it up this part of the presentation
with the quote by John Cenox that the
greater the machine's freedom the more
it will need a moral
standards. So interesting times because
we need to start engaging more into
moral into ethics and philosophy not
morality ethics and philosophy to
operate our technology.
So before before I close with the
summary, I wanted to point to a list of
interesting opportunities. I'm not going
to read them all um but I think this is
a very interesting list to take a closer
look for every executive. And one of
them for example would be to um simulate
synthetic reality before doing activity
in real life in the marketing in the lab
or somewhere else or maybe uh
understanding proactively loophole
lighouses regulatory or um finding M&A
M&A I mean mergers and
acquisition acquisition opportunities
and and kind of scout for them within
AIA agent and so on. So this is all very
exciting, all very interesting. I think
um we will need even more discussions
around philosophy, about ethics, about
uh social aspects of of AI and humans
and psychology. Um and this is a a
little attempt to to to do that.
Although there is a long list of very
interesting topic technical topics which
I'm not going to talk touch uh today. So
a brief summary of what we discussed is
uh agents. So I took quick technological
perspective of of agents and then we
discussed uh the AA agents adoption from
workflow perspective. Then we discussed
it from the network
perspective and we touched also the
challenges and
opportunities. So executive summary oops
that should be appearing as the last but
let me start with that. If your
strategy, everybody talks about the
strategy these days online and if your
strategy still makes sense when you swap
AI agent with some other word like
machine learning or or data and it still
makes sense after swapping that means
that strategy is already
outdated. Then I told you that agents
make a difference because of new
capabilities. Detailed workflows
understanding is crucial for bigger
benefit from the agent. We need to
democratize the agents to fully
accelerate a agent res
revolution. Looking at the network of
personas which is a human aspect is very
important. An organization must be ready
for rapid transformation and the whole
orc charts
might change
drastically. Also a mind mindset shift
is is essential in terms of um
redefining and being ready for different
interaction with the technology which
might be on some occasions even leading
us. And last, the ethics is still the
crucial part of of what we do uh in our
lives. So, let me thank you with that.
It's a wonderful conference. Thank you
for being part of it. Let the context be
with you. Take care.